so Matthew you and I have been seeing
each other for quite a while now and I
just want to let you know that it's
completely normal if you start to feel
an intense emotional bond to me as a
result of our work together okay can we
start therapy no sexual feelings right
about me in my body no you have them you
tell me well I don't so don't I'm not
it's not a thing
great fantastic that would be it that
would be a problem if that if that if
that were happening so I'm glad that's
not happening how are you okay so
there's this guy at work he's just he's
a bozo but it's like he's been there
forever and then it gets me thinking
wait I got what are you doing
oopsie was I being sexy no no well as
your therapist I just need you to tell
me if it ever starts to blur the line
between professional and sensual okay
not at all okay please continue all
right well anyway this guy he's just
been at the job forever and then it gets
me wondering like well what am i doing
at this job because I did I what is this
woohoo sorry I dropped my pen apologies
if my perfect buttocks are making it
hard for us to have a strictly
professional relationship but I'm merely
looking for my pen the pen that you're
holding in your hand it's looking for a
different pen just stop you're right
let's let's continue thank you just
coming across my leg joke like come on
you're right it's silly that was silly
of me I always crossed this way can I
tell you about my week you're right
you're right yeah I sincerely apologize
I'm very glad and relieved that you
don't have sexual thoughts towards me
it's fine great Matthew tell me about
work so this guy this guy he's just been
there forever alright and then it gets
me thinking am I gonna be there forever
and I'm like am I gonna know when it's
time to say enough is enough am I ever
gonna like the guts to just leave the
place my friends are like just pursue
music that's where your talent is and
that's what exactly what I look no this
is way out of line like you're not sexy
I don't think you're sexy and I'm never
gonna think you're sexy so this is just
nuts
that's our tire duct yeah shake that
thing Oh same time next week
time to get some sleep